Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my new Joker 2 video.
We got a new first look at some scenes
that we're filming for the movie,
so we'll break it down.
There are a bunch of big comic book
Easter eggs and Batman Easter eggs
for the Batman comics.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I know there are a lot of questions
because of James Gunn's big
reboot of the DC Universe
about how Batman figures
into this universe,
because we saw our version of his origin
story during the first movie.
I will explain that during the video,
but based on Easter eggs around the set,
they say that it's
1983 during the events of Joker two,
meaning only about two years have gone by.
He's only been in Arkham Asylum
for about two years.
When he breaks out or he is broken out
because in these brand new scenes
you actually see three different jokers,
which will remind
fans of the Batman comics
of the three Joker storyline.
But what I actually think is going on here
is you see three different Joker,
including Joaquin
Phoenix's Arthur Fleck in his Joker
makeup running through the streets.
But it looks like Arthur
is running from the other two jokers.
You see Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur Fleck
character dressed in the gray suit
with the clown makeup still on, running
from the other two jokers,
one of them dressed like a regular rioter,
like in the regular street clothes
with the clown mask
from the end of the first movie,
and the other one dressed in his iconic
red suit with the same look
that he had at the end of the first movie.
He runs through the streets.
There are a couple of cop cars
that he runs past.
The other one rider with the clown
mask getting tripped up
and falling in the street.
There's a couple of different theories
about what's actually
happening in the scene and what's going on
with these other jokers.
The most likely scenario is that
these are two copycats that are trying
to help Arthur Fleck escape,
and he's running from the police.
That's why they're police in the middle
of the street with the parked cars.
The whole concept of there
being copycats was a big thing.
After the first movie,
everybody had theories
that there would be a copycat joker,
or at least one during the events of Joker
to his whole execution of Murray.
The big call to action speech of his
was fully televised for everyone to see,
making him a celebrity in their eyes,
inspiring more copycats.
And there were a bunch of people already
wearing copycat clown masks to begin with.
It's possible
that you have a bunch of copycats
here dressed as the different versions
of these characters,
like as regular rioters with the clown
mask, others dressed
just like Arthur Fleck
to help him disguise himself.
And that's
why he's got the clown makeup back on.
And part of his followers here are people
who idolize him, are trying to help him
escape.
The other big thing you may have seen
in these scenes they're filming
is that on the marquee here,
he runs underneath
there's the movie Bucket of Blood,
which is a Roger Corman 1950s movie
about someone who's down on their luck,
who accidentally kills the cat.
Then people view this
killing as an act of high art
and start to praise him
and he starts to seek higher
and higher levels of praise,
doing crazier and crazier things.
So it seems like they're implying that
that's kind of what's happening
during the movie.
Like Arthur Fleck gets praised
for his acts during the first movie.
People worship him
and he starts to do crazier and crazier
things, as do the mob of his followers.
And it's also possible
that he's running from them, too,
because the whole idea is that Arthur
doesn't do a good job of distinguishing
between what's really happening in
what he's imagining.
He's meant to be
a very unreliable narrator.
So it's possible
that some of this is happening
inside his head because there were rumors
that a lot of the movie would take place
inside Arkham Asylum,
like these three Joker's more of an ID,
ego and super ego kind of metaphor,
like a very Freudian thing.
And this is all happening inside his head.
The entire first
movie was an exploration on mental health
and the way that society treats
people like that, people with issues.
He imagined a lot of the events of the
first movie, especially with his neighbor.
You can let me know in the comments
what you think
is going on in this particular scene
with these other jokers
either chasing him or trying to help him
run away from the police.
But we do know that Harley Quinn
is going to be in the movie
played by Lady Gaga,
and she will be a real character.
Like she won't just be completely imagined
by Arthur Fleck's Joker character,
but you may have seen in your feeds.
Todd Phillips
also celebrated Valentine's Day
by posting the first look at Harley Quinn,
meaning Joker.
And he's actually in his classic clown
makeup.
His caption
just read Happy Valentine's Day.
And in the scene, you can see Harley
Quinn is just capped, elevated with Joker.
Like she can't believe what's going
on. She's so excited.
She's just so taken with it all.
She seems hypnotized by him,
which is kind of their dynamic
in the comics and in a lot of the movies.
Obviously in the DCU since that Birds of
Prey movie, they move slightly past it.
Like Margot.
Robbie's Harley Quinn
isn't enraptured with the Joker
as she once was in their relationship in
the comics goes back and forth like it's
meant to be the worst, most toxic
relationship you could possibly imagine.
They even covered that arc on Batman,
the animated series with her
leaving the Joker for a little while
and just going to have fun with Poison
Ivy and briefly
trying to turn good in the picture.
It looks like she's just kissed him,
like she's kissed him
because he's kind of flabbergasted
by it, like, hey, this is pretty cool.
And she's got his clown
makeup smudged on her lips,
which is usually the opposite way
these things go.
Usually it's the girl
who smudges her makeup on the dude,
but because we're talking
about the Joker here
who wears clown makeup, he wears
way more makeup than Harley Quinn,
even though she eventually does
wear a version of that make up to it.
It seems like at this stage
in their relationship,
she hasn't got to that point yet.
But you do notice they are both in plain
clothes, which means she may have
already helped him escape Arkham Asylum,
allowing them to actually change clothes.
And for him to actually be able
to put the makeup back on.
If the movie really does explore the idea
of what happens with these copycats,
like this group of jokers
that start to idolize him
and they start to commit crimes, too,
it turns into more of an actual mob,
like there was a mob
during the first movie,
but they were mostly riding
against the local government.
It's always possible
that something happens
by the events of the second movie
where that turns into full blown villainy.
And if you don't remember the three Joker
storyline from the Batman comics,
the whole idea is
it was playing on the possible
different origin stories for the Joker
because the whole idea
is that in the history of Batman comics,
you've had a bunch of different
origin stories for the Joker,
and no one is meant to be
the definitive one.
The whole idea is that
Batman is never meant to be sure
whether or not
the Joker is lying about his origin story.
You want to know what the scars
kind of like
Heath Ledger's Joker where he said,
Do you want to know how I get these scars?
And every time he tells his origin story,
he tells a different story.
That was also a play on the whole idea
of the three jokers.
There was the criminal,
the clown in the comedian.
The criminal was the pragmatic,
philosophical, surprising, serious joker.
He's meant to be based on the Golden Age
version of the Joker, and his main goal
is to inspire
Joe Kill to become a joker clown
worthy clone that will eventually kill
Batman's parents.
The clown is based on the Bronze Age
version of the Joker from those Batman
comics and implies that he is
the one that almost killed Jason Todd.
Robin turning him into Red Hood or
causing him to become Red Hood eventually.
The comedian is based on the more modern
version The Joker and implies that he's
the one from Batman The Killing joke
that wound up paralyzing Barbara Gordon
and each different Joker
just has a completely different
ethos about why they are the Joker,
why they became the Joker.
So Bruce Wayne would still be a child
living with Alfred.
He be a little bit older,
but still be a child and there wouldn't be
a bunch of Batman stuff happening yet.
This is the list of every single DC movie
and TV series, this coming up
and where it fits into the canon
in the way that James Gunn said that
they're treating the Joker movie
in the Batman movie with Robert Pattinson
is they're meant to be complete elseworlds
projects outside of his DCU.
They're calling it the DCU. Now.
That means when they introduce
the new version of Batman in the DCU,
the older one who has Damian Wayne.
If they do the Joker
at some point in the DCU movies,
it'll be a completely different
joker again, not the Barry Keoghan one
and not the Joaquin Phenix one.
Let me know in the comments
Who do you want them to cast?
Is that version of the Joker?
Remember, because it's an older Batman,
it would also probably be a slightly older
version of Joker as well.
Willem Dafoe
as the Joker would actually be pretty bad
as the bit a couple of big DC trailers
that have dropped in the last week or so.
So I'll do new videos for that.
You can click here for my brand new Flash
trailer video and click here
for all my Mandalorian Season
3 episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.